well it looks like joe biden's getting
some backup in his war against the
second amendment his pick for attorney
general judge merrick garland
says he'll have biden's back when it
comes to pushing major gun control
policies take a look
do you support banning banning of of
certain types of firearms
the president um is a strong supporter
of gun control and has been an advocate
all of his life uh his professional life
on this question
the role of the justice department is to
advance the policy program
of the administration as long as it is
consistent with the law there is room
under the law for the president's
policies to be pursued
then i i think the president is entitled
to pursue them
joining me now for reaction on that and
much more jack carr former navy seal and
author of
the devil's hand jack thank you so much
for being here so we'll just get your
reaction to the potential
new attorney general and then we'll talk
about some other things
sounds great thank you so much for
having me on now my friend chris cox
recently reminded me
that the real tragedy here is that we're
even having this conversation about
second amendment sanctuary cities
because these rights in particular the
second amendment
was paid for in blood by those who
sacrificed their lives their fortunes
their sacred honor so that we could
enjoy the freedoms
that we have today and these are natural
rights they were very clear our founding
documents
were very clear that these are not
rights given to us by the government
therefore
they cannot be taken away by that same
government now in the military
we raise our hand we take an oath and we
swear to uphold and defend the
constitution of the united states of
america
against all enemies foreign and domestic
we don't get to choose
which part of that constitution that we
want to uphold and defend and then we go
into battle
sent there by politicians who take a
very similar oath to
uphold and defend the constitution of
the united states they put their hand on
a bible
for them for the most part and then
their very next breath their very first
acts
are go to subvert that and restrict
these rights and consolidate power at
the federal level the irony of course
being
that they are feet away from men and
women who are defending them
with the very tools that they seek to
ban for the rest of us
right exactly and the white house's
response to a record number of new
gun purchases last year is to restrict
them and they they put them in the same
category they talk about quote gun
violence
and then put in this new 8 million new
gun owners as if they
bought all of their their new guns
illegally
when it comes to their overstep in
wanting new policies and president biden
has said he may
implement some new executive orders but
you mentioned these
second amendment sanctuaries all over
the country and i think that's really
the key point here is communities all
around the country saying no you're not
going to impose
on my liberties you're not going to
impose on my natural rights you have
sheriffs in missouri saying that they
will arrest anyone who violates the
citizens gun rights
arizona is looking to shake up their gun
laws you have
fort fairfield becoming a second
amendment sanctuary and these are
these are just a few examples this is
happening all over the country
that's right so those three states
counties in those three states you just
mentioned
um are are amending their constitutions
to guarantee
the the right of the people to keep and
bear arms
now uh it's largely symbolic in that in
2009
montana county and montana did something
similar
it was not upheld by a federal court but
it was interesting an article by cam
edwards recently said we should use
the uh the california sanctuary city act
that makes it harder for
law enforcement at local and state level
to coordinate with
in this case the federal government so
there are some ways there that we might
be able to explore uh on that front but
very telling that the press white house
press secretary has asked
about two million gun sales in january
now those
come from background checks so legally
acquired firearms from the background
checks and it's still a problem
for this administration from a president
who has been surrounded
by government-funded uh security since
1971 for the last 50 years
yeah that's also an excellent point and
you're an author you think the first
amendment is very important can you
explain why the second amendment
is just as important as the first and
all the others
that's right so the i have an article
coming out called the
moral vanity of censorship and that
applies to the second amendment as well
there's a moral vanity surrounding those
who seek to restrict our rights to
defend ourselves
and our families and i would say that
for those that uh
that are thinking this way that are
voting in politicians that seek to
restrict our right to defend ourselves
and our families that it's not just
for us it's for our children and our
grandchildren and for future generations
and it's up to us we have that
responsibility to be good inheritors
of the rights that were passed on to us
and we need to pass those same rights
onto our children and grandchildren we
are citizens
not subjects and we must be uh we must
remain
uh ever ready and vigilant to stay that
way
amen well i can't let you go jack carr
before you give your biggest fans a
quick preview of your upcoming novel
because we're all waiting
it's the fourth in the in the series
give us a little bit that's right
april 13th and it's really about what i
thought about during my time in uniform
and what i continue to think about as an
author and
what has the enemy learned by watching
us on the field of battle
for the last 20 years in iraq
afghanistan syria and other hot spots
around the world
what have they learned and what have
they incorporated into those battle
plans
and in this case in my next novel the
devil's hand they're ready to strike
again
all right we are patiently waiting look
forward to that jack carr thank you so
much for being here tonight we
appreciate it
thanks so much